thank you very much for the nice
introduction but I'm trying to let you
know about when I sell the company and
then students ask me hey what to do next
so I tried to think another way so I
think about how we can perform or design
the accelerator in kind of a user
perspective so but but first of all I
review what we have done and what we
think here in the newer nav workmanship
that happens so country this aie row we
have different things such as a
computing power and the algorithm and
big data are they all the foundations of
this exciting era and you may see a
little bit on this figure there are
smart everywhere so especially in I
don't know whether it is true in US but
it's true in China that people are
talking about smart cities small
retailer and smart everything so but
well we look into this smart everything
then we find out that okay the deep
learning is one of the major help from
the Amazon part so for the different we
have two parts one is training so you
give the datacenter a lot of data and
then you go through the supervised
training and you have the models and it
can be some of in some of the
applications you can be the human being
so then you download the model to a lot
of different devices in the client side
and then for the kansai you see a figure
or you have some voice then you can have
the translate into the meaning of the
figure or the voice so that's the
training and the inference part so when
we are having this internet and mobile
internet so people are generating lots
and lots of loss
data so when the data are trying to get
higher and more and more exponentially
then you need to find some way to
consume this data so deep learning is or
the machine learning part is one of the
algorithm that can consume the power by
the deep learning and using the high
where's so the how where is support the
deep learning and the deepening is
trying to use the data so for previously
however people power is driven by the
technology improvements and they are
very beautiful because they are
universally likes the same right so for
the CPU part is is combined by the the
most basic operations such as the
multiplication at addition and so on so
forth so you use this little operations
to to make every algorithm possible for
now is enter into differently era so
actually everything is defined by
application so people are caring about
performance so it may be jumped into the
occasion defined or application driven
design scenario and performance may be
the one of the key part for now so then
people are thinking we have a lot of
error so when you are in the PC era you
have the CPU and then I just list one of
the representative but there should be
more so maybe Intel is one of the big
guy at that time for the power support
and also the for the game you have the
GPU and graphics processing unit and the
media is one of the winner in this power
competition and for form you have we
have mobile chips and forearm and
Qualcomm and so on so forth you have
different or not that lot of different
paths
several different companies who wins a
lot from perspective at this time point
but for AI we think not only for the
Amazon part but for the power pod who
be possibly the winner so this is the
thing we are thinking about and also
this we make a kind of the market party
as a trading so it's comparing with the
100 billion and the others is much
larger because that we think yeah for
how I guys yeah maybe you need to put
every immediately make every device a
little bit more smart then the way is
you put somehow we're inside
so then how a volume will be very large
so maybe become a larger volume even
larger volume comparing with mobile
phones so maybe have a larger market so
that's why we think maybe for the next a
big company in the this for this AI part
will have a big company so I am a
circuit and system a professor in a
department Ching hai University and
actually I was a ETA guy one was doing
my PhD work dealing with reliability and
leakage power back into 2007 and then
when I graduate I I need to find a
direction which is different from my
professor because in Chinua and I still
stay in Shanghai I could didn't get get
outside and then go back so I need to
find out a different direction so I go
to Microsoft raesha at that time to be
an intern at that time to be an intern
then we do hardware in Microsoft
Research fascia yeah when we build a PG
card for the ranking system inside so
for one car you can use the hardware to
refer to we play about a dozen though of
CPUs and to have this large volume
ranking faster so after that when I go
back to the university I start to look
at this application so well we do a lot
so when I go back to the University I
start to look at all these kind of
application driven architectures but not
until 2011
we find out ok the deep learning is
booming right we have the image nail
competition and you have the voice
recognition and all things that is
computers in your network and the TT n
is the behaving much better obviously
algorithm so but for us it's only vector
in the matrix multiplication right so
then I told my undergraduate student hey
let's start to make a Hauer which may be
better than the current hour so what is
the current power at that time is GPU so
at that time GPU helps to do the
training part and so for us we cannot
beat the training part that time because
it's a dense matrix multiplication which
is which GPU optimize a lot for this
dense matrix optimizations of operations
so we try to look at the inference so
forth for the inference part we may have
some chances because there is a need
from the applications about the power
consumption and also the latency for
example if you're even in a data center
every all the data there and then you
need to processing all the data so the
the power budget all the data center is
some car somehow fixed so if you can
boost the energy efficiency of process
in the data then you you may have
provided more service so boosting the
power efficiency becomes very important
the lower the power when you do
something and for the embedded
applications the the latency is very
crucial for GPU at that time is not that
good so okay this is these are general
figure about the how to improve the
energy efficiency the first way is
feature size scaling down so so for this
way people are ok now is still saying we
will have for games from the feature
size going down but from 2005 they have
trying to do the beauty of the
customized accelerators to boost the
efficiency and now also in the
university and some startups that we are
trying to look at the processing memory
and computing and optical computing or
vice versa that is approach free which
is a new device and the new model but
today we are more on the second probe
which is the customized accelerators so
when we are looking into the inference
then we because we I do FPGA in
Microsoft and I know how to do some of
the so that is a starting point right so
what that's what starting point I ask
myself if we can build up an inference
engine which is better have better
performance for power
comparing with GPU so we did a lot first
of all we have when you are thinking
about to build up a whole system which
is more energy efficient then this three
treating is very important first one is
you need to boost the peak performance
and then then that means you can within
a restricted area you put more
multipliers or the additional errors
right and the second one is you need to
boost the the utilization of computing
single image if we take the image part
as a example right because when you when
you have 1,000 course they can compute
the multiplication there only 100 is
working that is now good right so it's
only one one of ten end of the hour
workers are working so that's not good
so that's the typical condition when you
use a big GPU to process a one image at
that time so you need to make every one
work and the third one which is also
very important is you need to get the
workload down that means you need to
have to something about the new now
itself by pruning our data accommodation
so we build up the whole throw them that
is I think my not the reason Ultimo jerk
a major reason that darlings acquire
defy because people if they have
cafe au tensorflow train the model you
can use this role to download it to week
also called deep learning process and
union so we build up a processor or
coarse grain iso processor here and then
we build up all these to flow we
integrate the new nests are compressed
in tuning and quantization and also we
build up the compilation from the Nunez
representation to the the compilation
through flow and also we build up the
hardware architecture and the whole
framework was presented in hardships in
2016 and 2018 so let's go a little bit
inside this these steps
so for quantization when we are doing
the new NASA inference which we find out
that ok it is enough for half in the
bowl you see we can see that only 1% of
the accuracy chopped down comparing with
the 40 points 32 if you use the 8 bit
and if you have the a bit fixed a bit
then you will have about 10% of the
resource on the FPGA comparing with you
build up a not prior or a header
comparing waste of floating points 32 so
then that means you with Xena PGA you
can put 10 times of more much higher
inside so that will boost the deer per
peak performance and the second one is
so we try to have this new and network
compression means pruning when you are
training than earnest so this work is a
joint work with Stanford students high
zoom is now a system purpose in that
mighty also a co-founder of the d5 so
when we the LST em on FPGA so we find
out that if you prune away nine
percent of the parameters you have
similar error rate
comparing with network that is not
pruned and based on that you design you
are not going to design a dense matrix
multiplication in FPGA you need to
design your sparse matrix multiplication
inside the FPGA so so we will have a
that is the ten times of pruning but for
the highway parties are only six excess
beta comparing with the original one so
then we design out to design how a
architecture so actually we design to
architecture one more fifth of the
convolutional neural network published
in 2016 and the other one is more on the
sparse matrix multiplication which is
more for the IDN part and prune in part
so we have that hidden past and the
memory architecture for that but we
think this one is important actually for
the CN part we are designed as a iso
based processor but for the DN part or
the RCM part we just stick as a
accelerator but for the processor called
DPU we build up this compiler to chain
which from the cafe parser to the graph
level ization of the interpretations and
we do some optimizations and combining
two with the CPU instructions and put it
on to the FPGA platform so this one is
actually a very be helped by the Zacks
platform because I was in designing so
see you have the view and also you have
the program logic so we put the program
logic as the GPU part and also there are
so for this compiler when we compare
with the
prisa the baseline work we have about
30% of the speed up comparing with our
own work here this is the 30% of the
speed are compared with the
non-optimized to work and also the
compilation time overhead is a quite low
you can see here are the compliation
jobs is about within 100 seconds for the
whole network so actually I go very
quickly about the compression and the to
flow of the the two Queen part and also
the TPU part so these three green lines
echoing parts are the basics of the defy
so we build on this technology and we
try to attack different applications at
that time we find out okay there are
three part which people have the most
needs one is the smart city part so the
video analysis the second one is in a
data center so every data were
transmitted to the data center and third
part is driving a system I'm not calling
it an almost driving but driving a
system so we not only build this to
chain and architecture but we also have
this software and reference designs so
that is the blue part we have the
industry application platform that means
we integrate all the software and the
GPU together so that people can see okay
then we need an audio/video analysis now
okay we will present you our video
analysis then then people can see how
can you have real time and you are
really fast and low-power so for others
we just send them the board and the -
okay you can try that right because this
is not the business and we start a
company in 2004 15 December and try to
raise money we get the money in Silicon
Valley actually in 2016 of February and
then
we start running around and in last year
July we are acquired by Xilinx so now
actually as I have already said
dying's there's a quick company and he
is building up all the FPGA is the
hardware but he needs reference design
and the IPC inside so what we did is we
have this highway IP of dpu inside and
then the to chain of how to map the new
nests on to the dpu and some reference
designs so it's actually our wing wing
if the two companies come together for
example if the lines go to a mobile
company then they need to bring some of
something that can show to or to let the
automobile company know okay you can put
the gangster PG inside because of you
have this kind of IP and you can have
this real-time processing of all the
videos when from the cameras so then you
have to we have the DP you and the D NDK
design kit available on the learnings
website and people are trying and also
using it you know some somewhere I don't
know where because I for now I'm I don't
know whether they have pushed to a lot
of for customers but I hope so so let's
take one step back to the bigger picture
this is a figure we try to draw and when
when our students are doing the
literature review so the x-axis is the
power so you can see from very low power
to 100 watts or 1000 was right and the
y-axis is Geoff's Giga operations per
second that means the performance and we
mark each one on it and this purple ones
are the
I think and the blue ones are the FPGA
and the green ones are the GPU so this
our basics so actually for now we think
for the energy efficiency that is the
lines across there means one is
typically one tariffs for what to ten
tariffs for what but you may see that a
lot of dots here right that is beneath a
below point one watt so they are mostly
the ICC paper or the Versailles testing
paper or something like that
but why and they can achieve over ten
tariffs for what or nearly 100 tariffs
for what but one or something is they
assume that all data are on ship
so that's trick then you can have a very
high energy efficiency because you don't
need to move the data on it so so let's
pay attention to more like over larger
than 0.5 watts
because four point five what is the chip
putting all the IP put into your phone
so I think about Apple Huawei and every
phone you have to soak on your
accelerator inside that that is the
almost 200 milli watts inside your your
phone so they are almost about one pair
of per watt or maybe slightly higher and
if you want to put into your camera then
is about 1 1 to 3 watts here so as high
as possible right so you can have the
highest energy efficiency and also if
you want to put into your car there may
be you need you need a 30 watt that is
the power of media spec so they have a
30 watt and so doTERRA perform for the
autonomous writing and for the for the
data center you
at around 100 watt the 100 watt so
that's yes typically the TPU and other
things is about 1.5 tariffs for what
something like that so also we have done
some of these ways of only the FPGA
inference text our readers and people
are trying to optimize the from very low
level here and neurons to the
convolutions to the layers and to a
network that is from the low to high
level and also they try to physically
optimize data bars or the memory or the
scheduling masters so and the green part
is only for FPGA such as you can use the
DSP for double mac so this is the only
thing that happens in the IPG but others
also can be applied to the Asics and for
the industry part okay that is a very
interesting though one of my friend
build up this figure is this is a
console called AI chip a landscape you
can see these these are grouped these
this is the tech giants and the system
provider right and this part is the IC
IC traditional IT vendor so you have
Intel and dying's and AMD and vice versa
everybody is cramming down okay we are
building their chips and you also you
have the startups in China this section
and also the startup world while and
also for every IP company and the
including synopsis and cadence and they
are creaming okay we are designing the
AI influence IP together we can sell
together with our our previous other IPS
so okay we have also compilers and some
benchmarks so this this one is very
interesting but what we think is most
different is the the system guys or the
system company are trying to get into
this area
everybody Google Microsoft and the
Facebook AWS and Apple we are in USB
creaming okay we are building our chips
and think about where we can use then
you can know why all these companies
they are trying to build out their chips
so typically we have the cloud and
terminal but we will form for me we
think I think maybe we can still have
some opportunities by the edge for edge
fire is a base station so you have we
are talking about 5g so there are more
base stations if you can put somehow a
computing power in that base station
then you can play your game right so
already have something more efficient
because your communication with the base
station is much faster when you talk to
the the cloud or the back pack data
center so and also the cars and routers
may be some kind of routers in your home
right so all routers in the factory how
to crack the data and how to process a
little bit of data with a privacy and to
provide better service so we don't see
much more here but we see a lot in crowd
and terminals the terminals the phones
and cameras in the cameras computers and
vice versa
so I try to include some of the recent
trips that in the news right so this is
this one is re Baba's Hong Kong wishes I
think it's the more recent one and also
how we view our SM and Google TPU 3.0
and akka and in health
spring quest and I didn't list the phone
part but these are trying to suit
themselves to the edge and terminal part
so what we think is so okay we are
trying to have growing of the
computation power yeah every big company
or the become they are trying to build
very large chips such as hundreds of T
offs in the in a single chip and also
the urge
to put them together to get a car sir
half of P flops such as TPU and aqua
quali and also this big wafer skill chip
announced in this year hardship so we
already have a lot of choices now from
the small chip to the car so what is the
next so we can expect AI platforms
covers everywhere so I have somehow
covered a little bit and we are we
already have many Messer to make this
trip very powerful so what is the next
what still we can do in the university
especially for accelerator guy like me
so we I'm still thinking about this so I
discussed with my students we are trying
to for the other things so that is some
case studies I trying to show the main
idea so the first one is the application
is edge and the cloud and maybe the edge
so the first we're starting from the
edge we is trying to use the same
accelerators in the moving robotics so
the fundamental reason is that sand is
gaining quickly improved comparing with
the previous messer we can see for the
feature point instruction you have you
can have about Tony percent higher
accuracy than the handcraft Messer and
also the face recognition attempt
percent higher than Hancock method and
also the object attractions so if we
build up a small robotics a robot roof
of moving robots then you have the
feature part you need to do the feature
point the extraction each frame and you
you you need to do the price recognition
may be several frames between so we will
have this video audiometry that is the
feature point distraction oriented and
there you get your position so you have
a saline backbone from the info Zn and
then the okay the we have only one TPU
because your embedded
for me is not that powerful right so
then you have you go into the price
recognition and you have the C end
backbone part one why because you need
to do the next feature point instruction
for the next frame so you need to have
interrupts here so then you have your
change back to the feature point
extraction and then you change back to
the place recognition so that will make
your if you want to improve you have
multiple salient talks on a single DP
you then you need to integrate the
interrupt feature inside but how to get
a interrupts inside then we we just
think about okay the interrupt response
of they have about this four stage you
need to finish the calculation here
sorry
calculation here and you need to back up
all the other data order in the register
or everything on chip and then you
change to the hybrid a task and then you
do the recovery and do the calculation
again right so you have this latency of
T 1 plus T 2 that is the calculation you
need to do and backup time then you have
the cost of these extra cost of the
interrupt so how to ensure that the
easiest way is we just do it like the
CPU so you just stop immediately and do
the backup and change to the high
priority task and do the recovery but
the backup all the data on chip is quite
large so you need a lot of effort and
then because the newness is layer by
layer right so you can do these after
one layer then you have to back up a
little bit of data so then you can do
the calculation or waiting for the
backup and then change to a hard work
for the task but this will wait for
finish the entire layer so we find out
that okay for the CPU like the backup
and recovery time is very high and for
this interrupt after each layer you have
to wait for a long calculation time then
how to do that so we try to find
interrupts at some positions with very
small extra cost so this is example when
we calculate in one layer so when you
are calculating one layer of chunk of
data like this then you just start with
sorry we start with the how we repair
ISM you can only consume this much of
data and then you need to do it for time
a lot of times to consume all the input
data and generate the output future map
so if you cut at this time then you need
to have a lot of intermediate data so
will we find out is if you cut at this
time you just finish all the input
channel for a parameter of ahead of four
that is a one time of the trunk then you
may have only about the one point six
percent of the whole computation time of
the layer for the worst case so this is
what you need to wait so you need to
wait one point six of the whole layer
computation so then we try to insert
some virtual instruction because we are
still based on the instruction base or
TP use and we input some virtual
instruction in the inside and then we
can or when you do the real job we have
a interrupt presented and then you try
to find the nearest virtual instructions
and try to put it into the backup and
insert the backup and recovery
instructions then you can do that so
this is a simple idea here and we build
up the multi Robo expiration with the
wrath and this
interruptible dpu on fpga so that you
can for each of the FPGA you can do the
feature point direction and the pressure
condition together and we make it the
real time apart or fulfill the
requirement of the system and we see
that okay this is the our proceeds prove
marking blue the cost is very low
it's about 1.5 million second and if you
layer by layer then is quite large
depending on where you have this kind of
interrupt request and if you do this if
you like you will brings a very high
extra cost back up so this one is for
the interruption so still and when we
look at the sharing on the count part
because for the they are building up big
chips so when you have a very very big
chip how to use this picture but so
first of all you need to look at what is
the workload on the cow so actually the
inference is the major workload on the
cow and what we find out that if you if
you have a very big Apogee so for
example you have 2,000 RDSP in that ipj
is a big FPGA but if you are trying to
do the use all the resource for single
neurone s you have you will not have the
linear speed-up
you have become lower and lower if you
use more DSPs so then if you want to
process multiple tasks in a cloud then
one single story so can we use one FPGA
for one task then if you use one I pick
you for one thought you you you would
like to maximize the resource
utilization then you have the best feed
but in a crowd people have some
computational power requirement but
their requirement may not be the fastest
so then you have some waste on the on
your resource inside so then we I fee if
you do like this you are trying to do it
by time division or max practicing so
that means if you are doing the task 1
and talks to I wanna be here you have
every show of latency like this of to
set to 30 sec meter second but if you
can just have to course a to small
course using 100 1000 DSP has one DP you
and they are not using our 2048 as one
big DP you then you can have better
average latency so this one is trying to
have the hardware resource sharing so
you need to have to integrate the
feature of how a resource sharing so but
the workload on your cloud they come in
different time so when you have a DM
model to come in at 12 o'clock and run
on the VGA and then you can use a big
accelerator to to accommodate your tasks
and then if you have another one comes
out of 2 o'clock then you need to change
your aperture into two cause maybe then
you can satisfy both requirements and if
you have more than you have to change
your FPGA in two different things
think about this FPGA is not only one
but it's a multiple right so you need to
have a multiple different accelerator
allocation see in different FPGA but
thinking about if you are having this
kind of a dynamic reconfiguration then
it is much more better than if you use
are either based accelerators but even
if you use the ISO base accelerator you
need about 10 to 1 here seconds just
like my the compiler part shows then you
need to take an extra one a 10 to 100
seconds so then can we lower the change
or overhead of the reconfirmation so
what we
okay that's look at the compliation flow
again we find out that the tops rate
actually is not related to the how air
allocation so you can use the top two
three stage the graph level optimization
of operator organization and parameter
generation these are not related to the
highway so you can you can and the third
party is a highway resource allocation
so you can use the first way as static
compiler and this still takes about 10
to maybe 100 seconds and this can be run
offline and then you can use the dynamic
compiler or kind of how a resource
allocation to generate the real
instructions by the however resource
allocated so integrate using this kind
of idea we are trying to put sorry we
are trying to put changes the original
stack into two stage combination and
then we integrate more modules into the
how where to enable the our resource
pool and also the two level of
instruction dispatch because one level
is a task level and the other level is
the module level so for for this part we
will we will have above a slightly
longer compilation time of static one
compared with the original compilation
and we have the contest which cost this
is the dynamic part and then about with
the transport time is about one to two
millisecond comparing with doing one
time of the Nunez is not that big so we
think it's okay to accept that one
and we also trying to use the some
simulation measure but this one can be
improved when we are using the real
scenario but we first of all we use some
simulation to
to generate some traces and then put it
on to one of each year so the we find
out okay we have about using the
virtualization we will have lower
latency and also the higher throughput
so this one is more on the cloud and
there's still one year so if we can have
a reliable known as from the our
perspective so we well we I'm familiar
with it's the FPGA so when you're not
chips means for tolerant then you have a
lot of different sources such as the
environmental effects and here we are
thinking about the radiation problem but
also you have the inherent properties
such as aging or immature device
technology and also you have some
security problem we'll talk later so
what we find is we do some very simple
simulation we find out that okay if you
change or disturb about 20 to 30 picked
parameters in one layer among several
thousand then the unit will fail that
means that you have almost lower than 1%
of the accuracy so it's useless right so
you only need to disturb about twenty to
thirty and each level then you will have
this kind of a fail so most we think
that we try for almost all the popular
Nunez
so with observe that most of the neural
nets have a fraction of notes
we call it key points which influence
performance a lot so then we are
thinking about okay if this point are
the most important part of the key point
so one way is we are trying to have some
redundancy for this key point and
retraining an earnest to help to protect
these key points so this is the for the
reliability part or you can just protect
this these key points so that when
people get all your protected ways they
can
use your nearness right so this for the
security part so we do some very simple
exploration on the reliability part we
assume that okay for the how where you
may have the radiation now if you have
the radiation then you have bit flips
right so if what if the bitterest
influence a lot of family or data inside
your earnest so we may jury consider
about this random bit proof here but for
others such as the thermo noise or
manufacturing or also can be modeled as
fall and input into this framework so
what we are trying to use one of the
weapons from the algorithm guy is the
nos so network architecture search so if
we can find some new nests which is okay
have some photon features so the model
the fault model is the Pease so wipies
so if if you know a little bit about
fpga you have the lots to build up the
logic right so if the last is destructed
by the radiation then you can change the
function of your may be much much higher
so if we we only have about 1000
multiplier inside so if one of the
multiplier is broken then you will have
a lot of errors right because you are
using this modifier again again again
during the holes in calculation of the
new owner
known as so then we do a simple
simulation then you can see that if the
fault rate becomes larger maybe 1% of
the four injected then for Reznor oh
it's okay but it's not that good is 65%
of the accuracy but for mobile net is
job to 15% so it's a four different
different types of the architecture and
the connectional Nunez have different
tolerance to the source of the false so
this is a
very interesting so we may explore some
of the architectures can torrent right
so this is the starting point so we
changed the knots framework to
integrated the search space we change a
bit about the search space and we change
the loss and the photons to integrate
this flock models inside so with ways
are without the loss we ork we do
experiments so we we find out that okay
for the experiments the model
architecture really this is the random
variable a percentage of the nearness so
if I now okay these journals will job
when the random beliefs becomes Roger
and also we find out okay well and when
we find the our the best newer models we
find out to read on those connections so
they are trying to add the redundancy by
the training itself into the nearness so
which is very interesting but we don't
know why yeah and according to this we
try to modify the ResNet block just like
this into this kind of run you done in
the connections keeping the flops were
saying so that's look at this one first
so if we call it Resnick column at M so
it will behave better than the previous
resident so kind of redundancy will be
better so this is one of our finding and
we also keep the computation flops and
the parameter total parameters so then
we after our search we have the using
the with the loss integrated always our
not loss integrated and we have much
better tolerance to the random bit flips
so we did can use the network actually
self 2000 some for injected so for the
four fourth power is a secure
so that then we look at the nominal
memory part so now the memory is kind of
just like at the beginning you're saying
that okay we move the data to the memory
of the memory much near to the data for
this one is trying to move the
computation inside or very near to the
memory so because the moving data cost
is much higher than a competition for
now
so actually we start this kind of
anantam memory base accelerator from
about 2012 they use this memory crossbar
to have this function like just like the
vector and matrix multiplication so it's
just as the same as the mathematic
expression of the neural nets so
actually we have not we but we can see
the Accademia the building of chips in
icc and also this year and last year and
there are some startups doing the flash
base or the big company which which is
working on the PCM so this these are
what we did in the last five or six
years but we are not going to that part
but we're trying to talk a little bit
about the security part because for
non-volatile memory if you can read all
the power you'll still have the data
inside that memory right so then if you
get the device then you have some method
to to read each other cell then you can
read all the weights out right so you
can read each other ways out then you
are leaked your information so previous
for the non one time applications people
are trying to do the encryption if you
have the print has to start there then
you encrypt using the key to this
encrypted tax and then if you are using
that you use a key to decrypt that but
for newness if you are going through
these layers are or putting on the
normals and memories so they are there
and if you are trying to encrypt all
this you are trying to do with ten to
100 million of ways so this is a large
volume that means you need to do massive
write operations but massive write
operations will be very very dangerous
because for this emerging memories they
will have orders of differences in the
write endurance for example for the our
Emperor is about five orders of
magnitude lower than the Astra so it
means if you do it again again then you
have a broken ship very soon right and
also you will have a very large right
latency so you cannot bear to do it
again again so then we can do in a
secure way the problem so the problem
changes into how to find these very
second significant ways and only encrypt
this ways and when you use it it just
decipher this weight and use it so we
try to develop technologies so called
sparse fast query and the encryption
then it's fine the most important ways
so I am NOT going to the detail this one
so we have this model and do the
inference about propagation on this
models and we find out that mostly
important a waste maybe 20 or 30 of each
layer then we do some small
perturbations on this waste to do this
to do the encryption the small
perturbation means you need to keep the
waste changed ways within the typical
weight distribution order layer so that
you the others will not find out that
you are trying to modify the voice in
the layer so then we these are the
results if you have encrypt about 25 of
the ways inside one layer of different
neural Nets then you can have a large
drop of the accuracy but for vdg
is not that case but so vgg is quite
redundant so then we try to put a bit
more so this is the pretty big diameter
so if you put them in more then you can
see if you set the parameter to appoint
you then you will have drop and twenty
five or twenty or so the weights inside
that layer so and this just shows okay
if you put up in a little then it's good
and within the distribution out that one
and you will if you're doing much larger
then you you will be easy to detect you
are doing some modifications in that
nearness so then you can select the
equipment configuration for different
neural nets for example for right now
you just you can use twenty encrypt
weights and with perturbation of 0.2 and
is so quite large or for the Reznor you
use a 20 and a small perturbation so
this is the one we are trying to explore
so actually we are trying to think about
what to do when you have a lot of AI
computation power and you have a menu
master to make the chip powerful from
the power efficiency or the computing
power part then you need to find out how
to do it user friendly customizable
low-cost real-time or reliable and
secure so you need to weigh more
different angles or different points
around this part so people are doing
like this part but it so I think is a
weight more things to be researched from
so that concludes my talk and thank you
very much
[Applause]
yes so the question is using the
important bit is a very interesting idea
but so you still need to store the key
right so where to store the key yes yes
so and the follow-on question is where
to store the key and how to select the
weights somewhere on the chip okay so
actually this is a very good question
but what we are thinking is so
previously there was some area on the
chip is secure so we can put on that
apart so this is a traditional security
problem in the highway part so just we
just assumed that we can have it there
but we didn't really build up that I
think the key contains the position the
direction or the perturbation and also
the intensity or the perturbation yeah
the question is even if you protect some
of the key part but if you leak others
maybe you can reconstruct the whole new
or nests based on that information right
so actually this is a direction we are
still looking at for now because you can
use some of the all the gradients to to
guess about the weights so if you have
the gradients then you can you can have
the waste but we didn't do the
simulation if you encrypt some of the
ways and then have the gradient because
you can't have the chip right so you
can't generate the gradients encrypted
with the key parts right so then if it
can be restored though we didn't do that
simulation but it's a very interesting
direction we can look at and try to
review that if we can do that then this
this work is not so so the question is
the bit flip in the memory becomes very
important of last for 20 years so what
if it is a problem inside the FPGA right
so well we are looking at this part so
let me go to the when you are when we
are trying to look at we look at all the
memories such as the you put the weights
and the future maps into the RAM so the
ramp are you may also have this kind of
it because these deals as ramps so you
may also have the bit flips but that it
depends on how you design your new Ness
accelerator and how you access the data
maybe it will be flush refreshed by new
data so if you refresh by new data then
this flip bills will not influence many
of the others so if you know influenced
many of the others data during the
calculation of the larger Ness you may
not have a dramatic change of the
accuracy in the end so it depends on if
you have a flip inside the memory
how large of the impact we will have in
the end so this is a pub form for us we
do some calculations all simulations we
didn't find very large impact on the
part we have so this is a question about
if you do some detection part of this
error so actually we are doing that
ongoing working back in the universe
video we are trying to do that yes
because if we if we consider a chip then
there are multiple sources of this beef
ribs so we only look at the peas for now
but for memory hotter and we are still
doing that
so for the configuration part I you
there are special technology to to
protect them but for others they use for
Thoren technology yes
yeah maybe so one all the way yeah okay
okay thank you very much